how would that affect America in some
regard you know if if Trump comes in and
says it's payback time [__] what
would that look like for America
great it would be the best thing ever I
don't think there's a negative I think
we're talking about is a bunch of kids
playing on a playground a bunch of
bullies who have been going around
shoving the kids in the mud they shove
Donald Trump in the money gets up and
it's payback and all the kids are
sitting on the playground watching this
one guy go back and get revenge on the
bullies I don't think it affects us in
the negative at all in fact I think
it'll make things better I think he'll
secure our borders I think the economy
will greatly improve I think he'll bring
jobs back I think you take a look at the
foreign policy of Donald Trump and uh
I didn't vote for Trump in 2016. I
thought he was Despicable
um then he started enacting policies
that I was very happy to see and I still
found him to be quite despicable he's
he's a he's a potty mouth guy he's nasty
he imitated body slamming a journalist
and I'm like I don't care if you don't
like reporters I don't like the
corporate press you know don't do that
um but you know I remember uh first
simply Abraham Accords historical
amazing
um crossing the DMZ into North Korea
with no security detail one of the
greatest acts of leadership I have seen
in my life and I think should be in any
other circumstance they would they would
be writing about it it would be the one
of the most proud moments of the United
States Donald Trump entered North Korea
enemy territory with no security detail
with Kim Jong-un surrounded by North
Korean soldiers
and it was funny when I watched that
happen having a family history that goes
to Korea and what that means to me
and I was nearly brought to tears and
then the media insulted Donald Trump
over that and that really pissed me off
when Barack Obama was President he uh
ordered a drone strike on a civilian
restaurant in Yemen a country we are not
at war with which killed Abdul Rahman
al-alaki a 16 year old American citizen
no one bats an eye he also killed Anwar
al-alaki in the argument he was a Jihadi
so it's War so it's Justified I still
don't think you can kill American
citizens just because we're at War
bombing a country we're not at war with
you know what people come to me and say
Tim it's War we're dealing with
terrorist factions we've got allies in
the region it's conflict you cannot
claim it's murder and I'm just like
I guess but don't come to me and then
insult Donald Trump for negotiating with
Kim Jong-un when you were bombing
civilians so I look at the North Korea
thing and it's and it's I wonder if I I
wonder about the the perspectives of
other people
who know exactly what it is to have a
family saying here's where we're from
here's the town your grandfather grew up
in because I have that somewhat on one
side of my family and not on the other
because I hear the story of oh you know
your your great grandfather was from
this this town in North Korea but we
have no idea because since the since the
splitting of the country that's it we're
cut off let me give you some credit
um and I'll tell you why I want to give
you credit is because Pat started the
entire podcast with basically your
Evolution politically right ideology
ideologically you've been all over the
map and you're you're kind of finding
your your groove right now but what
you're able to do is you're able to
separate personality from policy and
most people in America are just straight
up voting for their team they're voting
for their Jersey they're voting for the
personality they agree with they don't
go through the Nuance of policy right
here and essentially what you're saying
is you you actually to use your words
you actually found him to be disgusting
and vulgar and a whole host of words I
think you said Despicable at one point
but you still vote for them because
you're able to separate the personality
from the policy why can't most people do
that
I mean humans are social creatures you
know we we don't know everything about
everything uh the average person doesn't
know what's going on in the world
because it's not their job to and I
don't blame them for it I'm not going to
ask a plumber to read the news 24 7 all
day every day like I do yeah and so the
best thing they can do is say do I trust
this guy does he appear genuine to me
Barack Obama very much did so and for me
coming off of the Bush years of war and
ex and Military expansion in the Middle
East which was unjustified
to then be told Obama was the guy who
was going to put a stop to the unjust
Wars to see him ramp it up and then to
bomb kids the disposition the Obama had
something called the disposition Matrix
the kill list I don't know if you guys
are familiar with every Tuesday they
give him baseball card style sheets
saying like who do you want to kill
he made the decision to kill somebody
Kobe had one too
Kobe had Kobe Bryant it's a different
story
yeah he's throwing you off and so I just
see that I'm like I was lied to it's all
the same what's the point 2016 comes
around Donald Trump's running against
Hillary and I was just laughing the
whole time I was like this is America
the reality TV Real Estate Mogul against
the Deep State witch yes who said she
did not care if we went to war with
Russia because she wanted to own Syria
what a disgusting person and uh then
Donald Trump gets in
third party no I didn't vote I said
what's the point and uh probably looking
back on it I mean who was it um who was
the libertarian before Joe Jokers uh
Gary Johnson yeah and then he had the
Aleppo moment what is Aleppo I know the
[__] City and Tim it's crazy that you
say that about Barack doing all the war
and all the bombing of the innocent kids
Trump crossed the DMZ and shook hands
and everything guess who got the Nobel
Peace Prize Obama got the peace Donald
Trump strike a bunch of countries drone
struck or whatever uh Donald Trump or uh
ordered a Commando raid in Yemen which
according to family members resulted in
the death of abdullahi's seven-year-old
sister an American citizen
so there's there's challenges even with
Donald Trump so that's why I'm like look
you know you you're never gonna find
someone who is a saint who's doing
everything right right however Donald
Trump no new Wars Donald Trump Abraham
Accords Donald Trump withdrawal from uh
well the timeline for the withdrawal
from Afghanistan butchered by by uh Joe
Biden the dismantling of Isis the
crushing of Isis the removal of our
troops from Syria despite the fact that
the U.S uh top brass lied to us and
Donald Trump to keep troops in Syria and
then as soon as Biden gets in troops go
right back in the challenging thing for
the American people is there's no way
they're going to know about the history
of the region there's no way I could and
there's no way they're going to know
about why we're at war in Ukraine so all
they can really do is say am I with the
am I with the people or am I against the
people what I view as the woke left
is not ideological the woke to me means
cult-like adherence to Liberal social
Orthodoxy crafted by social media
algorithms that's why they're somewhat
Marxist but also pro-war in Ukraine
Ukraine has supporting war in Ukraine
has no basis in critical theory or
anything like that so you have these
right-wing academics and liberal
academics who are like oh woke means
Marxist and all that I'm like it doesn't
explain why they're so supportive of
going to war in Ukraine like it's really
just adherence to the social Orthodoxy
because it's a survival tactic of human
beings I think if the average person
actually knew what was going on they
would all immediately oppose the war in
Ukraine they would I mean you don't
gotta like Vladimir Putin they would
immediately agree with Donald Trump on
most of his foreign policy they'd
probably vote for him again but most
people don't know that they rely on the
lies of people like Hillary Clinton
blinken or or Joe Biden and that's the
challenge what can you expect them to do
if they don't have the time to read all
of these news reports all of these
scientific studies
what can they do but this goes back to
Pat's initial point go buy a [__]
media outlet and get your narrative out
there yeah but you know just like we
just circle back to Vice George Soros is
funding Vice I mean not like not a Jeff
Bezos wapo anything like that I mean
extreme far left so
you kind of said that Republicans are
just kind of minding their own business
they're buying buildings they're buying
businesses they're buying corporations
but they're not buying media Outlets
like Trump's not a republican he's an
Insurgent candidate who entered the
Republican party because it was the only
path to win he was a moderate New York
liberal and even vox.com in 2015 and
2016 called Trump a moderate candidate
and if Trump wasn't a billionaire he
probably could run as a Democrat and win
the problem is tax the rich Bernie
Sanders he wasn't going to get that base
so Trump campaigned for the Lost
Americans people who never voted before
and independent voters and he won them
over they come into the Republican party
and start pushing people out Trump also
converted nine million Obama voters into
Republican voters this pushes the
Republican establishment back Trump
would not have won among Republican
establishment voters hence why you see
people like Bill Crystal and and uh you
know the Lincoln project people now
supporting Democrat candidates because
that's closer to where they were in
terms of establishment politics so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]